nous accueillons neutralité du samedi 20
heures ce soir jonathan destin bonsoir
alors je m'attends
pendant 6 ans
de 10 à 16 ans vous avez été harcelés à
l'école
vos bourreaux vous ont battus ils vous
ont rackettés ils ont menacé de tuer vos
parents si vous parlez pendant six ans
vous n'avez rien dit à personne vous
aviez trop honte vous aviez trop peur et
le 8 février 2011 vous décidez d'en
finir de vous suicider en vous immolant
par le feu à l'âge de 16 ans cette
histoire vous le raconter dans un livre
publié chez xo est intitulé condamné à
me tuer vous nous raconterez à 20 heures
[Musique]
m
je n'attends destin re bonsoir
vous êtes né le 9 décembre
1994 à lille votre père frédéric employé
à la sécurité incendie votre mère marie
pierre fanneau foyer les deux soeurs
plus âgés que vous vanessa et aurélie
peu de temps après votre naissance votre
famille emménage dans une jolie maison à
marquette lez lille rue de la paix
le seul problème c'est que vous ne
prenez jamais de vacances il faut payer
le crédit de la maison votre père
travail de 7 heures du matin à huit
heures et demie du soir et vous le voyez
très peu en fait oui très peu
à l'école vous n'êtes pas très à l'aise
devant le tableau noir et on décèle une
légère dyslexie oui par rapport aux
autres j'ai beaucoup de mal à répondre
en classe vous ans ouvrier où ils pokou
résultat vous commencez à vous replier
sur vous même il faut dire que vous êtes
un enfant assez timide assez peureux
oui je suis né comme ça j'ai peur qu'on
me juge oui exactement
et votre famille vous aviez peur qu'elle
vous juge on lit aussi voici la famille
aussi
dense est en cm2 que vous commencez à
subir vos premières brimades des
moqueries des insultes d'abord sur votre
nom destin alors les mômes vous dise
c'est ton destin d'être nue c'est ton
destin d'être gros à 11 ans vous peser
déjà 70 kg ont laissé sa crise at me
traiter de croo est pas en peluche
manche est ce que ça me réconforter
alors on vous traite de gros cons de
gros porc enfin c'est très difficile vos
parents commencent à avoir des doutes
sur ce que vous subissez en dehors de la
maison et un jour votre maman vous suit
discrètement et ce qu'elle découvre fait
froid dans le dos c'est un matin
j'allais tranquillement mené coll il y
avait des petits jeunes qui s'étaient
cachés derrière une voiture et qu'ils
ont commencé à me jeter des cailloux et
ça va parce que ma mère était là à
lapider arrêté et étirent à leur
proviseur qu'une juste et cailloux ils
ont défini alors quand vous arrivez en
6e au collège vos craintes d'avoir
affaire à des grans confirmé d'ailleurs
c'est vrai les choses ne tarde pas à
déraper un groupe de quatre vous prend
grippe oui ça commence d'abord par les
petits chrome os par ci par là après ils
ont commencé à me taper me des coups de
pied des coups de poing alors le prof
principal vous dis c'est pas grave ils
ne font que s'amuser avec toi m'ont fait
il s'en fout oui le prof y avait perdre
les autres élèves ouais mais je le
sentais qu'il y avait perdre ouais une
fois un prof avait-il quelque chose sur
des élèves qui m'avait frappé et le
lendemain il s'est fait crever les pneus
de sa voiture c'est ce à dire qu'en fait
les profs ont peur des élèves donc ils
vous laissent finalement être la victime
de tous et ses gamins qui vous
torture
alors la cantine devient rapidement un
enfer pour vous oui justin la nourriture
de l'eau
me mettais copié sur les tables de
tétouan
alors vous en parler à votre grande
soeur elle va voir un jeune pour
l'engueuler et là c'est pire que plus on
leur dit arrêtez de faire ça plus ils le
font évacuer continue donc vous ça vous
renferme encore un petit peu plus sur
sur vous même
alors dans la cour de récréation c'est
pareil
oui en fait je me cache idem dans les
cases l'escalier et le professeur est
arrivé en fait et ils matif aller jouer
dans la cour il faut faut jouer avec les
autres mais moi je voulais pas lui dire
qu'en fait quand je suis attristé pour
me faire tabasser vous n'avez pas osé
lui dire lui s'en doutait pas il y avait
des surveillants qui tu voyais que je
nous ai tapé ouais mais ils tissent et
rien parce qu'ils avaient peur encore
une fois des autres élèves en classe on
vous balance des buts papier en nous
balancent des stylos on vous balance des
gommes en vous pic avec des combats
on vit tous les jours vous étiez le
souffre douleur de la classe
en faut dire que vous êtes dans une
école sans punition
alors évidemment les élèves ne
respectent rien et prof laisse faire
puisque a pas de punitions dans cette
école
beaucoup c'est prenant rarement
par vos parents ne savent pas la vérité
mais ils perçoivent quand même votre
mal-être il vous changent d'école pour
vous mettre dans une autre école une
classe au rythme ralenti adapté à vos
difficultés mais là tout de suite les
plus grands repères une proie facile en
fait
alors un jour vos bourreaux vous cogne
la tête contre un mur
et le professeur est venu voir ce qu'on
faisait et il a attient by day est tombé
en fait voilà évidemment jonathan vous
sombrer dans la dépression chez vous
vous passez votre temps fermée dans
votre chambre à pleurer en écoutant du
métal a
ensuite atteint mais c'est que ça qui me
calmer 1 metallica alors vos parents en
fait ils voient bien quelque chose qui
se passe mal mais il croit une crise
d'adolescence et vous vous n'osez pas en
parler à vos parents pourquoi n'ont
toujours pas ce que j'avais très honte
et j'avais toujours peur des
représailles 1 vous dites dans ma tête
j'étais comme dans une prison plus je me
taisais plus j'étais malheureux
c'est là vous commencez à être racketté
sur le chemin de l'école en quelques
semaines un régime de terreur s'installe
tous les matins votre mère vous donne 5
euros pour acheter un sandwich et une
boisson vous ne mangez pas vous donner
l'argent à vos tortionnaires en finisse
et même pour avoir de l'argent par piqué
dans le sac de votre mère là vous avez
honte de vous en plus mais servent aussi
alors là vous commencez à nourrir des
pulsions suicidaires et vous commencez à
regarder sur internet il suffit de taper
comment se suicider
le 6 février 2011 quand vous rencontrez
vos tortionnaires pour la première fois
vous essayez de vous défendre avec un
canif oui j'ai fait un tour sur moi même
en fait avec un canif et j'en ai blessé
un d'entre eux ou au torse
alors là vous dit bon voilà je leur ai
fait peur je me suis débarrassé d'eux
mais le lendemain quand vous les voyez
leurs menaces traîne une autre ampleur
l'un d'entre eux un revolver il le pose
sur votre crâne et il vous dit demain tu
ramènes 100 euros où on te fait la peau
oui ça déjà 5 euros j'avais beaucoup de
mal et donc sera un recours moi c'était
impossible
j'avais pas les moyens
et là je n'attends vous décidez d'en
finir le 8 février à midi vous vous
rendez dans un supermarché vous acheter
une bouteille d'alcool à brûler quelques
minutes plus tard vous êtes au milieu
d'un prêt au bord d'un canal le canal de
la deûle et vous vous renversé le
contenu de la bouteille d'alcool à
brûler sur le torse
d'autre issue non pour moi il n'y avait
pas d'autre solution je n'ai pas pensé à
aller en parler à votre maman non parce
que toujours j'avais peur des
représailles
vous dites à ce moment là je veux que
mon coeur brûlé m'étouffe
vous êtes rapidement une torche
la douleur est atroce
mais la mort ne vient pas ça vous fait
tellement mal que là vous vous rouler
dans l'herbe pour éteindre les flammes
oui comme ton est fine oui on n'a pas
arrêté flins ça continue à brûler oui
vous courez vers le canal vous sauter
dans l'eau et le courant vous emporte
alors oui je pensais que j'avais une
loyer mais aller faire les péniches
ouais donc j'avais très peur j'ai
commencé à créer c'est à dire un
instinct de survie qui dépassent votre
envie de me suicider en laisse
dans le courant vous emporte mais au
moment où vous allez vous noyer une
femme sur un pont vous jette un câble et
ce câble vous l'attraper
miracle
voilà donc après deux mois et demi de
commun vous revenez à la vie avec votre
corps brûlé à 72% vous êtes vraiment
dans un sale état et le chirurgien vous
dit jonathan est ce que tu veux vivre
oui ou non parce qu'à ce moment là vous
êtes vraiment en bascule entre la vie et
la mort il vous répondez oui oui quand
le chirurgien m'a expliquée par où
j'étais passé
la mort les opérations eh ben
monti m'a dit tu es les personnes qui
m'ont sauvé la vie et moi je dis bah oui
il faut que je vis maintenant et ça vous
réconcilie quelque part avec l'existence
alors il faudra dix sept opérations et
un an de rééducation pour que vous
retrouviez une vie presque normale
aujourd'hui ça va mieux oui beaucoup
mieux aujourd'hui vous dites je m'en
veux tellement de n'avoir pas su parler
vous dites ça sert à rien de mourir
quand on meurt ce sont les autres qui
gagne oui chose du jeu qu'on s'en être
en vie
voilà
merci des témoignages
qu'est ce que nous voulons dire aux
jeunes aujourd'hui
sont rackettés surtout qu'il sans talent
ne restent pas seuls
merci jonathan
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de il
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu